welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and the pendrick's in the games
missing Easter egg search dredged up
some real spicy eggs but even after an
infinite number of rewatch is a dull boy
can never be sure if he caught them all
what a miserable visual detail recently
revealed by the movies of the effects
artists shed more light on one of the
shoutouts we caught after our initial
watch Arnim Zola the Hydra scientist
turned ghost in the shield machine turns
out the guy wasn't just mentioned in the
end game he made a fool fool cameo and
the more I think about it the weirder
this little cameo becomes like why was
Howard's start even looking for Zola on
the day Howard was supposed to be with
this soonly expecting whites only and
how did it totally start no to pick this
particular day do time traveled back to
if you ask me this is all a cameo and
Avengers in game has blown the lid wide
open on Howard Stark always a man of
mystery
even break it ankles with handshakes
what was papapapa stark up to in April
1970 what was this secret Zola project
and how far up the chain of the MCU
things we give about does this go sounds
to me like a total conspiracy yeah do
you think we're trying here maybe I'll
do it again or maybe I'll cave to the
hates of all things new and experimental
okay let us re examine the moments in
Avengers in game when Tony Stark two
layers deep into his time heist sneaks
into the base at Camp Lee high in 1970
in search of the tesseract and the
basement looking for dr. Zola have you
seen him yeah that doctor sold now
haven't I haven't seen a soul so Arnim
Zola was of course the Hydra scientist
who served Red Skull and Captain America
the First Avenger and he returned in
Captain Merrick of the Winter Soldier as
an AI on shield server who had corrupted
shields operations into Hydra flavor
chaos and evil for decades long after
his corporeal death essentially what
this AI is currently doing to new rock
stars ah
and in this endgame scene Zola's green
AI face actually appears on one of the
screens deep in the background now Zola
didn't die until 1972 but here in 1970
so well it could be testing his AI form
I'm sure he would be working out the
kinks on early generation betas a couple
of years before he would need to make it
live but why
what Howard Stark be looking for him
like we just kind of glazed over that
but it's weird right what if the reason
ties in directly with what Howard was
doing that day
and Tony's fraught relationship with
Howard that led to this day being chosen
as a time heist destination so think
about it why did Tony choose April 7
1970 as a day he and cap went back Tony
must have known it was within the window
Howard Stark kept the tesseract at Camp
Lee high at the same time that Hank Pym
was experimenting with Pym particles
presumably Tony learned this information
from flipping through Howard's old
journals but when it gives the date to
cap an endgame the date seems more
deliberate than just like a random day
within a window I know for a fact they
were there this big what are we doing
how I know zero four zero four zero
seven zero seven gives me nine seven oh
now it's likely that Tony chose this day
because of its connection to his own
history Tony Stark was born on the
firmly established date of May 29th in
1870 at which point thereafter perhaps
his family relocated and it's possible
the tesseract might have been moved so
Tony must have assumed that seven weeks
before his birth would be a safe amount
of time before any move would take place
but many of us picked up on another
interesting moment between papa stark
and papapapa stark in the elevator the
flowers is our big date tonight my
wife's expecting and too much time in
the office
Tony's reaction here is all surprised
Pikachu
he's like shook to hear that Maria Stark
is expecting shook because it's a little
awkward to be reminded that your mom is
pregnant with you maybe but a brilliant
mind like Tony's doesn't often forget
about or get surprised by eventualities
like he chose the state because of its
proximity to his birth the moment he ran
into Howard downstairs he must have
known this would come up so why pika
Tony maybe because something is off
about the timeline of Maria Starks
pregnancy like notice what Tony asks
Howard right after this how far along
she uh she's at the point where she
can't stand the sound of my chewing I
guess they'll be eating dinner in the
pantry again yeah Tony's reaction is
super mysterious here
he's emoting like seven different
Pikachu's it's almost like his wizard
brain just deduced some dark truth about
his own origin and here let us turn to
the comics so in the 2013 Iron Man comic
storyline it was revealed that Tony
Stark was actually adopted we found out
that way back when Howard and maria´s
Stark experimented with their son and
Maria's womb using alien technology a
sentient robot called recorder for 5-1
to genetically modify the fetus 4-5-1
wanted to birth an advanced human that
would help earth better protect itself
in the future so Howard ámoreá agreed to
let him do this years later record a
4-5-1 would meet Tony Stark in space and
tell him that he was genetically
engineered as a baby to be strong enough
to one day operate the god-killer armor
to defend Earth from cosmic threats much
like the suit of armor around the world
the MCU Tony Stark has always wanted but
it turns out record a 4-5-1 did not
genetically engineer Tony Stark but a
secret brother named Arno Stark Maria
gave birth to our know but some
complications I don't time to get into
led to the baby's health collapsing
after birth unbeknownst to her quarter
four five one and Howard and Maria hit
are no who would live on in a life
inside an iron lung it's still iron
really and to cover this up Howard a
Maria adopted a healthy baby boy who
became Tony Stark who've lived out
Arno's destiny eventually in this comic
storyline Tony figures out this
conspiracy finds Arno and the two end up
working together but back to endgame
Starks interesting reaction here
these brief seconds could he have
unlocked a similar conspiracy well I
could see the MCU going in a similar
direction maybe revealing a secret
brother or sister - Tony starts
somewhere out there still but I doubt
that end game right here intended on us
to read this sweet father-son reunion as
some kind of implication that Tony Stark
is adopted and he has a sick sibling
caged away somewhere at the other day I
do think Tony Stark is his father's son
but total conspiracy vos is also broken
in several places if it's a step too far
for you to believe that the confusion of
a Maria Starks pregnancy timeline means
Tony is adopted and his parents gave
birth to a secret sibling who's out
there somewhere let's look at Tony Stark
himself what do we know about him
well Tony Stark is quite the genetic
specimen he's a genius billionaire
playboy philanthropist he engineered a
near perpetual energy arc reactor in a
cave from a box of scraps he cracked
time-travel and he has sustained crazy
amounts of physical injury even from a
young age Howard Stark recognized Tony's
brilliance telling him in a secret film
recording I'm limited by the technology
of my time but one day you'll figure
this out and when you do
you will change the world Howard Starks
ultimate goal was a child who would
carry on his legacy to use technology to
bring about world peace and perhaps that
obsession led to Howard meddling with
his wife's pregnancy
remember genetic engineering was a major
component of Zola's work in Hydra his
past with red skull
showed him eager to breed a perfect
superhuman just imagine Howard pushing
this weirdo from work to make sure his
child is as healthy and genetically
perfect as possible this could explain
why Zola might have been avoiding Howard
in this moment and why Maria Stark hated
being around Howard
maybe Howard was one of those hands-on
dads who keeps bringing home all kinds
of crazy prenatal supplements or in this
case a particular comfort food that just
so happens to be a popular German side
dish that is probably laced with
vitamins Ola
this Medellin could have resulted in an
abnormal gestation period one that
contradicted the timeline Tony Stark had
been told and that could be what Tony is
thinking here along with the choice
language Howard Stark used in that
secret recording my greatest creation
is human Tony Stark once snapped at
Captain America everything special about
you to bottle maybe everything special
about Tony Stark came out of a can of
sauerkraut and that pika face says it
all his birth was a comment down below
with what you think Howard starts
mystery project with Arnim Zola was and
what total conspiracy you'd like me to
investigate next or if you would just
prefer humorless lists of movie Easter
eggs that you can get anywhere else
follow me on Twitter and Instagram at a
vas and subscribe to new rock stars for
more breakdowns of theories about
everything marvel and if you love this
shirt as much as total conspiracy VAS
does it was super generously sent in to
us from our good friend Matthew in the
UK or at that MCU guy UK on Twitter give
him a follow and thanks so much man
and thank you to all of you for joining
me and if there is any evidence for Tony
Stark being a genetically engineered
Hueber man it's his skin from when he
was 21 MIT kids are grease traps 21 year
old Tony yeah he clearly got the acne
gene switched off by his dad's Nazi
friend
[Music]